(soft music)
- Hi, I'm Carolyn Grambling
Earth and Climate Writer
for Science News.
In honor, of the 100th anniversary
of our independent news organization.
We are interviewing leaders in science
on the big questions in their fields.
Here we're going to be talking about
climate change communication.
That can include not only
ongoing research on how best
to inoculate people against
climate science misinformation,
but also how to just engage
with people on this topic
in these highly polarized times.
My guest today is Ed Maibach,
who is the Director of The
Center for Climate Change
Communication at George Mason University.
Dr. Maibach researches
public understanding
of and engagement in Climate Change,
and looks for ways to enhance
both that understanding
and that engagement.
Along with his colleague,
Anthony Leiserowitz at Yale,
Dr. Maibach received the
Stephen Schneider Award
for outstanding climate
science communication in 2020.
And this is work that is
needed now more than ever.
So Dr. Maibach, thank you
so much for joining us.
So in my introduction,
I mentioned these highly polarized times,
but of course that's
an oversimplification,
people aren't just one thing or the other.
And as you and your colleagues
reported about a decade ago,
there aren't just two
perspectives on global warming
in the United States.
You identified six distinct
perspectives in the US
on that subject.
- Yeah, absolutely and you
have it exactly right Carolyn
it's like when I started
working on climate change
almost 15 years ago now,
that sort of the lore out
there was that there are sort
of just two beliefs--and
I'm using that word beliefs
very intentionally here.
It drives some of my climate
science colleagues nuts
when they hear me talk
about beliefs because
their businesses is evidence and facts,
not beliefs, but
nevertheless, the rest of us,
we hold beliefs about what we think,
our climate scientists have concluded.
And the lore was 15 years ago that
there were two types of Americans.
Those who believed that
global warming was real
and human caused and serious
and those who chose not to believe that.
And that just struck Tony and
I as pretty patently absurd.
Of course there has to be
more nuanced than that.
So we did something that
in the marketing field they
call audience segmentation
analysis. It's pretty simple,
it's just using statistical data,
people's answers to our
surveys, and then running it
through a statistical
algorithm to look at,
look for people whose
answers cluster together,
whose answers are similar to one another.
And what we found essentially
was that there are,
six distinct groups.
We call them Global
Warming's Six Americas,
and it's been absolutely
fascinating to watch
those six groups evolve over the past
we first identified them in spring of 2009
so we've been able to watch them evolve
over the past 12 years.
And over the past five or six years,
what's been particularly most notable
is that the Americans who
were least inclined to believe
that human caused climate change is real.
We call them, in fact,
they're not inclined
at all to believe that
they're quite firm in their convictions,
that global warming is a scam essentially.
And that segment of the public
about five or six years ago
was one out of, approximately
one out of 10, 12% exactly.
And over the ensuing five or six years,
they have contracted,
they're now down to about 7%.
That's something we didn't expect to see
because when people hold
their views strongly,
they tend to hold them dearly as well.
Mostly they are not willing
to relinquish their views,
change their views.
But at the same time, during
that same time period,
the group on the other end of
the six America's continuum,
which we call the alarmed,
again about one out of 10,
five or six years ago, 12% exactly,
they have grown enormously.
Well in excess of 25%.
Now, probably we're about
to release our latest data,
probably three and 10, 30%.
So there's been this enormous
growth in the proportion
of Americans who are concerned,
really deeply concerned,
about climate change.
- So I'm just going to
give people a little, like,
since those, the six
categories that you identified,
you mentioned a few of them.
So it goes from alarmed to concerned,
to cautious disengaged,
which I guess are the
people who just really don't
have an opinion one way or the other,
or feel uninformed about it.
I don't know if that's accurate
then there's doubtful and then dismissive.
And when you're doing these
surveys, like twice a year,
since 2008, when you did the
first one, is that right?
- That's right.
- That's why you're doing this.
You're able to do this
sort of longitudinal,
like let's track how these
attitudes have changed.
And I was interested to read that,
it wasn't just sort of like this uptick.
It was like there was a dip
and then it went back up again
over time. There was a
dip around 2010, 2011.
So if you can sort of talk about,
what are the things that
are driving those trends,
in people's perceptions, in your view?
- Yeah, that's a very good observation.
It hasn't been a single linear trend,
either upward or downward.
There's been a lot of
wiggling in those trend lines.
And the very first notable
thing that we observed
between our first and our second survey.
So between the fall of 2008
and early winter, 2010,
We didn't have the
funding yet in place to do
surveys every six months.
So, it was essentially a year,
a year 14 months between
the first two surveys.
But our timing was absolutely
fortuitous in the sense that
we caught the high watermark
of public concern about climate
change in the fall of 2008.
If you look at Gallup polls and Pew polls,
polls, that came prior to ours,
they were showing, sort
of a long steady growth,
and we jumped into this polling process
right around the time
of the high watermark.
And then--
- Was it like an inconvenient truth
was the year before, right.
So it was like, right around that
peak of interest in knowledge maybe.
- Yeah, an inconvenient truth
was I guess, 2006, perhaps
so several years prior.
what was actually going
on were two things.
I mean, a lot of things were going on,
but two things in particular
that I think drove this dramatic downturn
in public concern about climate change
between the fall of 2008
and the winter of 2010.
The first one was the
financial markets melting down
in America and around the world.
So, if you recall,
lots of people, their
mortgages were underwater
they were losing their jobs.
It was really a terrible time.
But something else important
happened at that time.
And it was called the Waxman-Markey bill.
And, namely, a comprehensive
climate legislation passed
in the US house of representatives.
And it was then going to,
it was going to become
the job of the US Senate
to essentially also ratify a bill
and come up with a reconciliation
and move comprehensive
climate legislation forward
to the president's desk.
And the president of course,
that was President Obama,
he would have signed it.
What happened in response
to the Waxman-Markey bill
is the climate denial machine
kicked into high gear,
like ludicrous speed
if I can use a Mel Brooks reference here.
- Spaceballs got it.
- Spaceballs thank you, exactly right.
So, the climate disinformation machine
is incredibly well funded,
incredibly disciplined.
And, when they kick into ludicrous speed,
it's going to have an impact.
And in fact that's
exactly the impact we saw
between 2008 and 2010.
- And so that sort of
dovetailed with the rise
of the tea party, as well,
as a political powerhouse I guess.
- Exactly, right.
- Yeah, but now we're seeing
this like swing back up
and in fact past the point of 2008,
as far as the alarmed and
the concerned fraction share.
- That's right, so really
for the past 10 years,
it hasn't been a perfect
incremental increase,
but for the past 10 years,
there has been this pretty dramatic growth
in public engagement, on
all of the indicators,
that we are, that our research shows
are most important people,
which we boil down to by the
way, five key indicators, okay,
because, there are really only five,
what we call essential truths
that when people understand them,
when Americans understand them,
it differentiates those
people who are quite concerned
about the problem and are
starting to take action themselves
from those people who
either aren't concerned
or aren't taking action.
And those five essential
truths are its real
meaning global warming is real,
its' us, it's human caused
experts agree, there's
virtually no disagreement
among that climate science community
about the reality of human
caused climate change.
It's bad meaning, yes,
it's bad for plants,
penguins, and polar bears,
but it's bad for people, too.
It's really important
for people to understand
it's not just a threat
to, charismatic species
up in the far north.
But in fact, it's changing
conditions in our backyard.
And then finally there's hope, right?
So for people who feel like
the horse has left the barn,
there's nothing we can do about this
in the words of some of my most
beloved climate scientist friends
who like to shorthand it
as we're F'd they say, no,
it's true where we are
in for a world of pain,
but the degree to which
we are F'd depends on
whether or not we respond to this.
And so people who feel
like there is no hope
are not likely to be
rolling up their sleeves
and getting engaged and championing
or personally engaging
in climate solutions.
- I have to say, when you said
there's hope those two words,
I immediately like took a
deep breath and went, okay.
So yeah, as a climate change
reporter over the last,
decade and a half now I guess
I've seen sort of this change in terms of,
where people seem to be
standing in terms of,
denial, outright denial.
And for me I can sort of recognize
what I think of as inflection points
there where it's like, okay,
the 2018 special report from the IPCC
on the one and a half degree study,
that seemed like a thing that
really got people's attention,
suggesting that one and a half
degrees versus two degrees,
there's quantifiable differences
and here's what they are.
And then, the youth
climate movement in 2019.
But your data seemed to
suggest that this change
was actually starting a
little bit earlier than that,
that people were becoming
more engaged and more aware
even before 2018.
So I was curious,
what are the things that might be driving
that particular tick upward?
- I suspect most Americans
have paid a lot more attention
to the youth climate movements
and to young Greta Thunberg from Sweden
than they have paid to the
IPCC's 1.5 degree special report.
I personally pay a lot of attention
to the IPCC's 1.5 degree report
because it's such an important
statement that they made.
The statement, I'm sorry,
I'm sort of going down
answering a slightly different
question than you asked me,
but I'm going with it anyway.
The reason why the 1.5 degree
report was so important
is because that all
countries in the world,
minus ours during the
Trump administration,
but now once again,
we're back in the Paris Climate Agreement,
and all countries in the world
have agreed to work together
to try to limit global warming
to no more than two degrees centigrade.
And yet they were smart enough,
insightful enough to ask the
IPCC is that actually safe?
That two degrees turned out
to be a politically expedient
number, a number that all
the nations could agree on,
but it really wasn't
clear as to whether or not
that was a safe level of warming.
And so they asked the
scientists of the world,
in the form of the IPCC,
to do a special report
on exactly that.
Would we be, what is the
difference for our children
and our grandchildren and their
children and grandchildren
etcetra, if we limit the
warming to 1.5 degrees,
or if we let it go all
the way up to two degrees,
God forbid we don't go beyond that.
And what they found was that it's really,
the difference is quite profound.
The, public health
I'm a public health
professional by training
so I tend to think of all of
this in public health terms,
the public health consequences
of letting the warming
get to two degrees, as
opposed to 1.5 degrees
is pretty consequential,
I shouldn't say pretty, it
is extremely consequential.
There will be a lot
more public health harm
if the world warms to two degrees,
then if we succeed in limiting
the warming to 1.5 degree.
And I do think so, now coming
back to answer your question,
I do think the public has paid
attention to young voices,
which is good.
There are children,
there are grandchildren
we should pay attention to them,
they're speaking truth to power.
And in fact they're
speaking science to power.
I think young Greta is absolutely amazing
in the way she speaks science to power.
But I also think that
America's health professionals
have by and large started to wake up
and talk about this issue,
which I think helps as well.
I can tell you for a fact
that America's television
weather casters have
really gotten in the game
over the past five, six, seven years.
And so there are lots of new voices
who the members of the public
weren't previously hearing
who are now talking about climate change.
And I think what we're seeing in terms of
this dramatically heightened
public engagement,
I think we're seeing that the sum total
of all of these new voices, who really,
you can say they have
ended the climate silence
that was raining in America
up until about five or six years ago.
Most people simply didn't
talk about the issue.
And we learn,
we know that from our surveys
and we know from our surveys
that most people don't hear anybody else
talking about this climate
change as an issue,
whether that's professionals
or whether it's their friends and family.
So the fact that America
has started a conversation
about climate change is incredibly helpful
'cause we're not likely to stand up
and do anything about our problems
if we're not talking about them.
- Yeah, there was a scientist
I talked to back in 2019,
it was Kim Cobb actually at Georgia Tech,
and she was mentioning like at that point
after the youth climate movement,
it just felt like suddenly
this was a kitchen table discussion,
that it was something that
people were sitting down
and actually talking
about amongst themselves
or in the grocery store
or wherever, as opposed to
just sort of some rarefied distant thing.
And it feels like, the
extreme weather events also,
which were again emphasized
by this year's IPCC report
to sort of bring it home
to people that seem to also
help make it more real, I think, yeah.
- Yeah, absolutely, and
so climate scientists
have been telling us for a very long time
that one of the ways that climate change
is going to touch our lives
first and most directly
is through extreme weather.
And 10 years ago, when we
ask people the question,
have you personally
experienced global warming?
About one out of four people
would say yes to that question.
Now about half of our polling respondents
say yes to that question.
And when we asked them well in what way
have you personally
experienced global warming?
We see very clearly that
more and more people
are connecting the dots between
the extreme weather
events in their community
and this thing that
they've been hearing about
called climate change.
- Yeah, I was also really struck by
the most recent report that updates
the six Americas showed
that the smallest fraction
is now the disengaged fraction,
that it just goes to show
that more and more people
are at least coming down
on one side or the other,
and, mostly on the
concerned or alarmed side.
So I thought that was really telling too.
- There's not very, there's
fairly little demographic
difference between the six Americas.
The disengaged segment is
the one sort of exception
to that rule.
They, have less household income,
they're essentially a group of Americans
who are working twice
as hard just to keep,
keep paying the rent or
keep paying the mortgage.
And so the reason they are
disengaged is not because
they don't care it's
because they don't have time
to actually pay attention
to sort of the news that had they,
if they did have more time,
they might otherwise
be paying attention to.
So, yes the disengaged segment has shrunk
considerably over the past decade,
and although I don't actually know
the numbers off the top of my head,
I can tell you, rather
than sort of inching along
to the next group over the
cautious and then the concern,
and then the alarmed,
my guess is many of them jumped straight
from the disengaged segment
into the alarmed segment.
- Yeah, I was going to I
wanted to ask you about,
so now that you have done this work
to sort of know the audience,
how is it helpful to develop
climate communication
strategies to be able to
identify these different groups?
How can you tailor different strategies
to the different groups?
- That's a great question.
And to some degree we do exactly that,
but the way, the biggest
insight for me personally,
in the six Americas continuum
was the following realization:
The alarmed segment, again
they've grown enormously,
so when I first started thinking
about the alarmed segment,
they weren't nearly as big and
important as they are today,
but even then, the goal there,
the climate communication objective
there shouldn't be to further worry them
'cause they're worried enough.
It should actually be
to help them understand
the actions that they could take
that will be really genuinely helpful.
And we know from our
polling that lots of people
have a very, even in the alarmedsegment
had to have a very unclear idea
about what actions are going
to be genuinely most helpful.
So with regard to the alarm, we try to,
and we try to help organizations
who are targeting the alarmed
segment, understand, look,
help these people figure out,
what's most important for them to do
'cause they want to take action.
On the other end of the
continuum the dismissive segment,
frankly we don't go after
them, we're not in the business
of trying to convince people
who don't want to be
convinced of the truth.
It's just really hard to do that.
And, if others,
there are organizations
who are trying to debunk
the misinformation that
characterizes their thinking,
God bless them.
That's not the way I
choose to spend my time.
I choose to spend my time
on the four America's
in the middle of the continuum.
And the reason is because, to
a greater or lesser degree,
they already understand that
the climate is changing.
The group that we call the doubtful,
which is right next to the dismissive,
they tend to be skeptical,
but they're still listening.
They tell us very clearly in our surveys,
they are still open to learning more
and as long, so just because
they're a little skeptical now,
as long as they're still
open to learning more,
I see that as a real opportunity.
So the four segments in the
middle of the continuum,
we have spent a fair amount of our effort
trying to build communication programs
that reach out to them.
That help them either
understand, as I said before,
that it's real, that it's us,
that experts agree, that it's
bad and there are actions
we can take that will make a difference.
For the segments who are already inclined
to understand that it's happening,
what our objective there
is to help them realize
this isn't only a future problem
this is today's problem.
This problem is already
changing conditions
in your backyard in ways
that, sometimes are nice.
It's gorgeous where I
live today I went outside
for a little while today,
and I was just stunned
at how lovely it is.
I understand why it's so lovely
and the reason isn't good,
but it is lovely today.
So we try to help people understand
people who see climate
change as a distant problem,
distant in space, somewhere
else, not here in my community,
distant in time, 2050,
2100, yeah, but not 2021
and distance and species, polar bears,
but not people. We try to
help all of them realize,
no, in fact, this is happening now,
here, in our community, to us.
And it's not good for us.
And we have real strong reason
to believe from our research
that when people learn
those facts, they learn the ways
that conditions are changing
in their backyard now,
and why that isn't good.
It helps to heighten
this public engagement
that we've been talking about.
- I was going to ask, I mean
I'll give you an opportunity
to critique journalists.
So this is obviously,
I think in climate journalism,
there's certainly been an increase in
recognition that we need
to tell personal stories,
local stories, make it, bring
it home to people in that way.
And I'm curious,
what do you think that
climate journalists like me
could be doing to tell this story in a way
that might actually be
impactful for that middle?
- Yeah, like the old expression
that all politics is local,
I tend to think that,
all climate change public engagement
comes from local motivations.
So I really do believe that
we've got, Science News
does wonderful climate journalism.
The New York Times, The Washington Post
are absolutely outstanding.
The LA Times. We have some
premier news journalistic outlets
that are doing outstanding
climate reporting,
but I would like to see
every day news stations,
both TV, radio, newspapers,
digital news outlets,
I'd like to see them
covering climate change
as a local issue
because people can only be
expected to care so much
or to pay so much attention
when they learn about
what's happening elsewhere,
because they're primarily interested
in what's happening here, in our town.
So I think we have a real profound need
to help journalists around the
country and around the world
do highly engaging
local climate reporting,
contextualizing the global story
in the form of local stories.
What's happening here, to us, now.
- So in the vein of, figuring out a way
to bring the story and make it personal
and relevant to individuals.
I know that you have this
story that you have told before
about a neighbor, who you,
I'm going to make you tell that story.
Do you mind sharing that one again?
I think it's really interesting.
- I don't mind.
I really ought to tell my neighbor that
I'm sharing our story publicly
but I actually don't think she would mind.
So I've lived in this
neighborhood for a good long time,
more than two decades now.
And for the first decade or so,
a neighbor two doors
down, her name is Nancy
she felt the need to remind
me every time we talked
that she is a, I'm forgetting
what kind of Republican
she tells me she is,
but basically she reminds me--
- I think you've said,
I can just tell you,
I think it was a Goldwater.
- Goldwater thank you that exactly right,
a Goldwater, I want to say
a Rockefeller Republican
and I knew that wasn't right.
A Goldwater Republican, which
is even more conservative
than a Rockefeller
Republican by a long yard.
And I really wasn't sure what about me
that was eliciting this need in her
to remind me that she is
a Goldwater Republican,
but, whatever, she and I
were perfectly cordial.
There was never any animosity
or strife between us,
but she and my wife and
some of the other people
on our block are in a
reading club, a book club.
And one night, I came home from work late.
I was teaching a night course
and Nancy was in my home
with a bunch of other of our neighbors
and Nancy wandered away from
the book club conversation
and she wandered into the kitchen
when I was eating the
leftovers from the book club,
like, I won there, and we had a long chat
and the long chat came from the fact that
I remembered that she had told me
that she's a vegan of three decades.
And, it really hadn't occurred
to me until that night
to ask her what's a good,
nice Goldwater Republican like you,
do with eating a vegan diet.
And so I asked her, I
didn't ask her that way,
but I asked her sincerely.
And it launched us into the most amazing
intimate conversation about
her real deep feelings
about the wellbeing of animals.
And she just can't bring
herself to eat animals
because she feels too
much empathy for them
and to want to end their lives
for the benefit of,
her nutritional needs--
- Or desires.
- Or desires, right.
And that, letting her talk
to me about her motivations
and what she cared
about, brought her around
to asking me about my motivations
and what I care about
and why is it that I
work on global warming.
And it gave me an opportunity
to tell her exactly why.
I don't really remember the details
of this part of the conversation,
but I'm pretty sure I couched it
in who I am as a person
and as a professional
I'm first foremost, and always
a public health professional.
This is how I've spent the
past four decades of my life
working on behalf of
ensuring that we can all live
a healthy and fulfilled lives.
And explaining climate change
to her as being rooted,
why I'm working on it is 'cause
I am a health professional
and I can't possibly stand by
and watch us destroy the climate,
which is the most fundamental
determinant of human health.
And being able to make my
case to her and explain it
from the perspective of my values,
made her comfortable enough to ask me
a lot of followup questions,
questions that she had in her
mind about global warming,
but had never found, created
the opportunity to ask anyone.
But because we were having
a real moment there,
she felt comfortable
asking me about the answer.
Did I know the answer to these questions?
And I would say,
we spoke for the better part
of 45 minutes about this.
And it was really a moment, I treasure it.
- Yeah, I was thinking, it's,
we're going into the Thanksgiving season
when people are going to have
these interactions with people.
And one does wonder,
what are some tips that
you might recommend
for creating those moments? I guess
I mean, I guess we're looking
for the common ground.
- Yeah, I hear that question a lot
and behind the question,
there's usually an assumption
and the assumption is
how can I win the argument?
And I think that's a really,
really bad way to think
about the whole thing.
And it's totally
understandable why you would,
if you want to engage, right, right.
You're alarmed and lots of alarmed people
would like to talk to their loved ones,
their neighbors, their
friends, their family,
but they're worried that
it will start a fight.
And they're worried that
they somehow have to,
essentially be, become
mini me climate scientists
or be able to channel
climate scientists to
put all the facts on the
table and win the debate.
But that's just not the way it works.
The way it works is you show
people how much you care.
And, once you've shown
them how much you care
and why you care, then they
might actually be interested
in posing some questions
and examining some,
aspects of this that they
otherwise really wouldn't be
in the least bit interested
in talking about it.
So, what I recommend is that
if you want to talk to
people about climate change,
and I hope everybody
wants to talk to people
about climate change, just start with,
telling people how much
you care and why you care.
And that's likely to lead to
a really good conversation.
- So it's funny as you
were mentioning the thing
about wanting to win an
argument, which, fair,
I'm also thinking about like the sort of
research that has been going on,
and I've written a little bit on climate
misinformation, disinformation,
and efforts to combat that.
And I'm curious, what is your,
it's an interesting arena
because it brings in these areas
of cognitive science and social psychology
into the climate space.
And I'm, there are all these like tactics
that people are trying to counter
with other kinds of tactics.
I'm curious about what your thoughts are
on how those efforts are moving forward.
And you mentioned earlier,
I know that you're like,
well, God bless those people for.
- No, no, no, this is a
really important question.
And I'm going to couch the start
of my answer in what I know
as a public health
communication scientist, okay.
So before I started
working on climate change,
I hold a degree in public health
and another degree in
communication science,
and I did that very purposefully
'cause I wanted my career to focus on
how do we use communication
to help people,
not just ordinary people,
but our policymakers in particular,
how do we use information
to help people make better decisions.
Decisions that will more reliably allow us
to, more people to live
long and helpfully.
And there's one and only
one thing I know for sure,
in my four decades of
study on that question,
and that is: every successful
public health campaign
in human history,
probably every successful
communication campaign
of any type in human history,
has succeeded on the
basis of having simple,
clear messages repeated often
by a variety of trusted voices.
And, the trusted voices part is important
because we don't necessarily
all trust the same people.
So I would contend that Donald
Trump is an absolute master
of simple, clear messages,
repeating them often through
his own trusted voice
and getting people in his milieu
to repeat his simple, clear messages.
And that was a very, very
powerful driving force
in America over the past
four years, and still is
very much so.
Much of what he's saying
has no basis in truth,
certainly no basis in scientific truth,
but if we want for those people
who are trying to communicate
scientific truths,
that will help people
make better decisions
we have to use that same toolkit,
simple, clear messages, repeated often
by a variety of trusted voices.
It helps to get the repeated often part,
it really helps have a lot of money.
So if I am, Royal Dutch Shell or BP
or ExxonMobil or Chevron,
I have a lot of money to spend,
to get my simple clear messages
out to the American people
and people around the world.
And right now, what do
I want them to know?
I want them to know that we've got this.
We accept the fact that
the climate is changing,
but we are putting our best people
on the task of creating new sources
of clean, renewable energy.
So, you folks don't
need to worry about it.
And it's a wonderful thing for
them to tell us, to tell me,
I hear it every day on
my NPR radio station,
I see it in my Twitter feed,
I feel like I'm surrounded 360 degrees
by the fossil fuel industry telling me
that they've got this thing, it's okay.
But the way they do it is 'cause
they've got a lot of money
to get messaged repetition.
They literally pay to get
their messages in front of me,
the climate science community,
they don't have that kind of budget.
So, and frankly, they and we
are not so good at the
simple, clear messages part.
- I was thinking that, yeah.
- Yeah, so we have some work to do
on simple, clear messages.
Taking the complexity of climate change
and climate solutions
and rendering it simple.
We've got a lot of work to do
on getting the message
repetition way up there.
And if we can do those two things though,
simplify our messaging,
make sure that we're finding ways
to get those messages out frequently,
the people who are most
concerned about climate change,
like you and me,
we will actually incorporate
that way of thinking
and those messages into
our own vocabulary,
into our own dialogues with
our friends and family.
And that's really the power
of simple, clear messages.
'Cause the most trusted
people in all of our lives
are the people who are closest to us.
So it really helps when your
messages are simple and clear
because members of your target audience
will eventually become the
conveyors of those message.
So coming back to answer your question,
the climate denial
industry has been changing,
has been shaping public understanding
on climate change for
many, many decades now.
They've been talking
about it for much longer
than the climate science community.
So we have a very hard
job of undoing the damage
that they have done in terms of shaping
our understanding of climate change
in ways that are
fundamentally just not true
and fundamentally intended to make us
not care about climate change,
to make us think that
it's a distant threat,
not a proximal threat.
And to make us...
Or that there's nothing we can do
or that we should pay most attention
to our own carbon footprint
which is completely ludicrous
because while it is good to
reduce our own carbon footprint,
we're never going to solve this problem.
We're never going to keep
the warming to 1.5 degrees
or even two degrees,
if what we're worried about
is our individual carbon footprints.
What we need to worry
about is making sure ,
that every nation in the world
has a real climate action plan.
And that that plan is focused
laser-like on limiting
global warming to no more
than 1.5 degrees Celsius,
which is why the upcoming
climate meeting in Glasgow,
Scotland COP26 is so incredibly important.
- I was about to ask you,
you're about to jet off
to Glasgow, is that right?
- I am.
- To attend this meeting, okay.
And I was going to say,
what are you looking for
when you go to this meeting,
what is your,
this sort of is going to
segue into a future question,
What gives you hope?
But I guess, for now
focused on this meeting,
what needs to happen there in your view?
- Okay so it was a great thing,
I'm actually going to start to
introduce what gives me hope?
The Paris Climate Agreement gave me hope
because the Paris Climate
Agreement is the first time
that every nation in
the world came together
and agreed on a goal.
The goal they agreed to,
limiting climate change,
the limiting global warming
to no more than two degrees
turns out to be not such as prudent goal,
but at least it's a goal, right?
We got that going for us, which is nice.
But, now we need to reset that
goal down to 1.5 degrees C
and there are a lot of voices out there,
including a lot of nations
that really aren't interested
in lowering the goal,
making a more ambitious goal
of limiting to 1.5 degrees C.
So it's incredibly important
that as many science-based
voices will be present at that meeting,
fighting for that, upping
our game, going big
so we can really try to limit
the warming to something
that could be reasonably
considered safe for humanity.
So what I'm hoping for is that countries
will increase what are called their NDCs,
their nationally determined contributions,
no country has to do anything
it's totally voluntary.
But if the people, if in my case,
I am going as a health professional.
So if health professionals
show up at the meeting
and make it perfectly clear
to our nation's leaders
who are representing us at that meeting,
that we expect them to
become more aspirational,
we expect them to fight hard,
not only to make bigger,
more ambitious NDCs,
but to push other nations to do the same.
So that's what I'm hoping
will happen at COP26
and, that gives me hope that
there's still the chance
that we can have an impact.
Every 10th of a degree of warming
that we avert will pay profound dividends,
profound benefits for humanity.
So I don't want to pretend as
if there's something magical
about 1.5 or two degrees C,
but every 10th of a degree of
warming that we can prevent
is going to be really a blessing
to humanity going forward.
- Yeah so I guess, the flip side,
this is, it's been a really
tough a couple of years,
really exhausting and
grueling both due to COVID
and for, extreme weather events
and, having hopes sometimes feeling dashed
about climate progress.
So I guess, I wanted to ask first,
what are your climate anxieties?
What do you feel discouraged about it?
And then, the flip side of that is like,
how do you counter that for yourself?
I guess, how do you, reach for that hope
even in the middle of this,
I don't know what the word is, mess.
- Yeah, right now I feel
most discouraged that
one possibly two US
senators are in a position
to essentially put the kibosh
on what otherwise would have been a really
thoughtful, appropriate, ambitious,
comprehensive climate package called
the Build Back Better Act.
It's just really perplexing to me that,
I recognize that this is
obviously a hyperpolarized issue
and that elected officials
want to keep their jobs,
so they want to make sure
that they are not stepping out
in front of and running a
foul of their constituents,
but this is an
all-hands-on-deck moment here.
And we have a moment in
America where we could really
do what is necessary, not do
everything that is necessary,
but take a major first step
towards comprehensive climate
action that will make us, for
the first time, a real leader
in the world. And the world
needs real leaders right now.
I don't have, I don't
think Americans should have
sort of that sense that the
world can't do it without us,
but we are so big, our economy is so big,
we have been such major
carbon polluters for so long,
we have an obligation to be leaders.
It's not just that we can,
but we have an obligation to do it.
So I'm a little bit dispirited right now
that it looks like the
comprehensive climate legislation
won't go through,
but I also try to take the
long view and realize, okay,
we'll it just means we have to work harder
and hope to create enough public will
to create enough political will.
So that next year or the
year after, or the year after
we will see the US Congress
do what is really necessary.
- Well, I certainly am
reaching for that hope as well.
I agree, I feel a little bit dispirited,
but I'm trying to sort
of, take the long view.
I think that maybe
that's the only way to
sort of move forward.
And, the idea of also,
trying to connect with people
and do what we can to build that story
and get the information out to people,
even in the middle of, even
and maybe not the dismissive folks,
but the rest of the folks, yeah.
- So to answer your question about
how do I contain my own anxieties
so I can continue to be
productive, I have a dear friend,
she's an emergency room physician
in Yellowknife, Northern
Territories, Canada,
and her name is Courtney Howard.
And Courtney says, I don't worry anymore
I just do the work. And I love that.
I love when she says that.
I wish I were like her.
I do still worry,
but the way I try to contain my worry
so that I can continue to do the work
is I've created a mental lock box.
And whenever I get new information
that I feel is important
to update my own
understanding of where we are
with regard to our changing climate
and what are most attractive
solution options are
I open up the box, I pay
attention to the information,
at least if it's dire information,
I shove it back in the box
and then I slammed the box
shut and I leave it shut.
And I only open it when I
need to update the information
that's in there.
And the rest of the time I just
focus on giving my best shot
at trying to help
people, mostly Americans,
but to some degree my work
is focused around the world,
especially in my work
with health professionals.
I try to focus on doing
my best work today.
And I find that that's enormously,
I don't know, cathartic,
I guess, in a sense. Staying
in the present allows me
to give my best shot every day.
- I was finding that
thought grounding, yes,
- Yeah exactly.
- Yeah, well, Dr.
Maibach, thank you so much
for such an informative and
eye-opening conversation
and viewers, you can learn
more about Dr. Maibach's work
and keep up with the latest
research on climate change
by visiting us at sciencenews.org
and connecting with us
on social media.
So thanks for joining
us and thank you again.
- Thank you Carolyn.
(soft music)